c'est dommage que le dispositif
anti-violence de Claude Allègre devrait
se mettre progressivement place
l'attache ne sera pas facile face aux
agressions on demande aux enfants
d'avoir du courage celui de dire et de
porter plainte faut-il encore que la
parole des enfants soit entendue et
qu'ensuite justice soit faite voici
l'histoire de David 13 ans qui a osé
briser la loi du silence en dehors de sa
famille personne ne l'a cru la justice a
classé l'affaire sans suite et la nuque
Eric de l'agneau T3 ils sont parus par
derrière ils m'ont pris par les fesses
ils m'ont soulevé et jeté dans les
escaliers et que j'étais en l'air j'ai
eu peur ça c'était très long
et je fermais les yeux j'ai pas si
j'étais morte cette chute qui lui a valu
une entorse à la cheville et un mois de
plâtre David ne pouvait pas la cacher à
ses parents alors il a commencé à parler
et puis il a tout raconté raconté les
sévices que ses agresseurs trois élèves
de sa classe lui faisait subir depuis 7
mois mais il me tapé une
gifs dans la nuque les coups de pied
dans le dos dans le ventre
et je disais rien puis
c'était par période et un jour ils m'ont
j'étais aux toilettes ils sont révise on
verra la porte ils m'ont secouer il
m'obligeait dessus mais avait dit que si
je disais quelque chose ils iraient
taper ma sœur s'il la connaisse tu as
l'école
ensemble et ils avaient dit qu'il
tapperait ma sœur qui me taperait moi
ses parents déposent alors plainte pour
violence au commissariat de police la
direction du collège entend David puis
ces trois agresseurs séparément leur
seule punition restera une rédaction sur
le respect d'autrui pour avoir poussé
leurs camarades comme le on n'a jamais
prouvé exactement
ce qui s'était passé et vu la qualité de
la blessure j'allais dire qu'il n'est
pas une blessure extraordinaire quand
même donc l'élève a dû être poussé les
élèves ont reconnu avoir poussé l'élève
ils sont punis ça s'arrête là
quant au Brumath subit par David pendant
7 mois elle ne seront pas davantage
évoquées le témoignage de son meilleur
ami ne sera pas prise en compte pas plus
que le rapport établi par la psychologue
qui a écouté David pendant plusieurs
semaines faute de preuve l'éducation
nationale classe l'enquête en dépit de
ses appels officiels à rompre la loi du
silence la parole d'un enfant ne semble
pas lui suffire
pas compte en tout cas parce que la
fabulation ça existe la fabulation ça
existe
le professeur principal ou un professeur
ce serait rendu compte de quelque chose
d'une manière comme une autre
si personne s'est rendu compte de
quelque chose ce qui s'est rien passé
rien non plus aux yeux de la justice qui
n'a jamais convoqué David mais à classer
l'affaire sans suite Danny recours
dernier espoir d'obtenir un soutien SOS
viol violence le numéro vert mise en
place par le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale là encore l'écoute est
approximative
j'ai vraiment pas eu le temps et il
faudrait que je le fasse et le sentiment
d'injustice est total
il y a une plus grande qu'une chose qui
est faite qui n'est pas punie qu'on ne
cherche pas à savoir on dit partout il
faut que les enfants parlent c'est très
bien c'est qu'ils parlent mais s'il
parle et qu'après on ne les croit pas je
vois pas l'intérêt qui parle
l'affaire remonte à mai dernier à la
rentrée de septembre David étant très
dans un collège privé et il a souhaité
apprendre le karaté
il m'a regardé me fixer j'ai fait
baisser les yeux j'étais content
il arrive parfois qu'un gosse de 13 ans
inverse les rôles et de nos adultes une
bonne leçon